给大家分享一个最简单的赚料小钱的方法
就是把你的工作把你的服务包装成产品
千两天给大家分享了我赚钱的系统
我看好多的留言是
看懂了
不会做
所以给大家介绍一个
最简单就是你
你几乎一定可以会做的这么一件事
可以多替这么一件事
先说一件事啊就是忙这个事是不能
让你支付的
你愿忙可能会越穷
为啥呢
因为你的时间都用到正钱的嘛
所以你没有时间就思考一些更高级的东西
你想想你每天干嘛每天是不是每天都在做重复的劳动
赚钱的方法就在这里边
先讲一个事就是我十多年前我当我老师
我这边特别的学习
所以卖学习把那个时候就掌握了
所以当老师是用学习赚钱那个方法
但是有个问题是什么呢
就你第一边
第一个当老师的时候我还在收一罪大
特别行本你再给别人讲的过程中你再学习熟狂的学习
我那是你学习最好的方法
你第二边你会发言在这个机会上可以改进
第三边你会出新
你讲多了以后你就吐了
这是真的真实的情况就是
我有一次就是
学习说个先说个春牛的事啊
我因为我我愿意研究
我愿意研究一个东西
所以我把一个东西能讲得很偷
因此找我讲的人特别对我
以至于今天讲明天讲或者讲
你看我会断的
有一次
就是
一个离拜讲的同一个课
有一天早上起来的时候
就是真的是生意形的反映我阿托了
因为讲的东西重复了
所以后来我就讲上一个习惯什么习惯的就是
一个课
就是我当些数的时候我刚研究的时候
特别研究的时候我起见课
等我讲的时候我就不讲了
反 因为讲的东西都重复的
但是我后来反而先
我把寶藏给人呐为什么
因为那个时候
我还不会做产品
所以大家听到产品这个事件我我跟你讲
我们很多人都不会做产品的
这为什么说要是你
普通人能做的事情呢
因为你要真的做产品还得学怎么做产品
要了解用什么用户定位啊什么用户画像啊用户的成图啊
什么通点养点手脸啊
其实我来发现错了
照有耳了
最简单的方法是什么
最简单方法就是
把你重复的那个部分提供出来
对吧 我举了一次啦 比如说我拍短片
哎 我拍短片它是有结构的
啊 我自己
最后总结说一个结构了 默认证一下都按这个结构的
这个东西就是重复了
它其实就是个产品
对吧 你拍拍拍你不知道还有什么牛选题
哎呀 怎么选题呀
我该怎么拍呀
你得有选题
什么事
这些东西你都是重复的 您重复的整理出来以后
后来发现
不就是小波同吗
好了 抱歉吧 坐上那个小波同
它是不是就产品 现在卖
发现这了 差不多的发现是他
没有任何宣传
发现是他
对吧 就是把你重复的东西转化成
一款产品
我再说一个更具体的意思啊 给大家分享
我们呢 我每个礼拜日的晚上
有明天晚上吗 每一个礼拜日的晚上
我会回答老伙你们的问题
就每周 原来是八个钱的六个
每周六个人 每个人二十分钟
我会深入的就回答大家的问题
刚开始的时候 我跟你讲 每个人的问题都不一样
这个人是这个问题 这个人是那个问题
那脑子要不断的切换
哇 这个这个真的是
消耗脑袋
所以这个其实
其实这个内部声音会你在
我其实后来发现就跟老伙
回答问题的时候 帮了老伙朋友说我发现对我的大脑
真的是一个联系 中美跟礼拜
都必须为此这种啊
深度的思考的这么一个联系
每个人都不一样
但是
等于回答问题多了以后 你发现
其实回答问题的透露
入境结啦 问题的入境都是一样的
文取的意思啊
结果所有的问题
他在问你的时候 你不能按着他的
问的问题去去
理解为什么
因为很尊不知道自己的问题是上
还要知道他就不是问题了
这就花很值了去啊 你好好思考一样
就是很多人不知道自己的问题是什么
他虽然问问题 但他不知道自己的问题是什么
他真的知道了 就当你知道的问题是什么 答案就有了
所以我其实做的每一个固定的问题是做法是什么的 就是当一个问题的时候
我思考的第一件事情不是他的问题 回答问题 而是他的问题到底是什么
所以我就尊重研究一个问题 怎么就理解这个问题 背后的问题是什么
掌握了一套方法
你看这是问题 然后在这个机会上才去接打 然后才是怎么样
然后我会发现有就是这个这个
固定的 然后是针对每人的场景 然后来就定
那么
我后来发现什么呢 就有很多简单的问题 说打的问题不行
简单的问题 其实我会发现我这个 我这套解决问题的方法
是完全可以够用的
然后呢 我就在我的社群里面做了一个江销户
就是简单的问题
就是你不用深度的探讨交流 再诺学生探讨交流的问题 简单的问题
其实我你看思考的方法 我已经够化了那条关键上了
你问 按照我的思想
这道问题背后的本质是什么
深入网分之外 然后解决这个问题在我的知识过一边有还是没有
有就基本上就可以会打的 你看
就是把重复的东西提出来
就够成了一个产品
那老伙就没一看方便 他不用老实面对你 因为他一问基本上现场呢
就出来了 他很方便 他每天都可以问
对吧 最后我来说 我很上事
为什么呢 因为一些简单的问题 根本就不需要我回答的 他就已经够成了一个产品 现在是我们
我们
说明最重要的一个功能
对吧
要注意他们
方法是什么 就是把你重复的部分
然后你把它听出来 但是这是一个前条件 第一你带做
你带做过很多边
然后你带做重复的部分什么 我们很多人的问题是什么
老去西养
我要做个产品 我想要做个产品 你看这个产品行吗 你看这个产品行吗
比如说 你有没学过产品 你不知道怎么做产品
你还没有做出那个产品 你不知道是怎么做的
反而这种方法会更好 就是干嘛 听全球的重复的部分
所以各位从今天晚上就可以试一下
怎么做
你就把你最近做的事
已经完成了事
你就針对他
拿出来
好 然后
列三一下 拿三讲第一
这件事就是
这个事里面哪些事是重复的
哪些事是重复的
把它一点一点 载出来
要做好
就在每一个动作 后来可以帮你做很多钱 哦
所以
战事来
好 第二个部分
哪些部分
其实是表面的东西
表面的 就是你看 比如说你我九例子 就是我原来是做资讯的
一个领域的公司 我去做资讯 其实我告诉你底层是一样
只是到了这地方
把数据 把啥东西换成这个公司的人
你做一个行业的资讯 都是这样的
你知道吧 就表面的比程中一样
对 还有些东西是需要你的领藏的
只有你领執
去只有你自己的那个经验和判断的才能说的
你要把它 变成
好 三个部分 拿下的
然后你会把这段有什么帮助呢
重复那个部分究竟的产品
只有你自己的那个经验
和你领藏才能做的那个究竟的特场
那个就是你的能力
你看 还有意思吧 怎么找到自己的能力赛场
天输啊 从这找
好 第二个部分
你把你那个重复的部分 把他整理出来
把他变成一个
埃修皮啊
有吧 变成一个产品啊 变成一个露银啊 变成一个AI啊
对吧 你
其实死啊 都可以 把他做出来
你三部 给外面人用
用的工作 以后
类似的东西都用他用的工作 然后你
不断的发现
体练 挑幽 体练 挑幽
好 经过几次那种时候 你就可以把这个东西
拿出去 销售着
你看见面
其实你会发现
你最忙的地方 你最重复那个地方
反而
可能是你的
第一个产品